In this video, we'll see a simple
type of conditional random fields,
no that as the linear chain
conditional random fields.
So we motivated the use of conditional
random fields in the context of sequence
classification where we want to be able
to jointly model the full sequence of
labels associated with a
sequence of inputs. So,
uh,
this here is essentially another way of
writing the probability of a given value
for y one up to y capital k,
capital k is the number of elements in
the sequence given the first input in
this sequence up to the
last input in the sequence.
Now let's look at how we,
uh,
will a particular parametrization
of this conditional distribution.
So perhaps the most simple,
a conditional random fields or
CRF is the linear chain a CRF.
Now let's see, uh, what is, uh, what
we do in the context of a linear CRF,
not in regular classification
where we don't, uh,
assume there is any dependence in
our model between, uh, the, uh,
the adjacent positions in a
sequence. Uh, in this context,
it mean it means that our distribution,
the probability that our model assigned
to a particular sequence why given a
sequence of input x will just be the
product of the probability that our neural
network assigned to each label.
Why k given its associated input x k.
Now,
uh,
in the neural network that we remodeled
this is that we take the soft max output
activation function.
So we take the exponential of the pre
activation value for the label for which
we are evaluating and probability that's
why came and then we divide that by
normalization constant
or partition function,
which is just the sum of all
potential value of the numerator.
So this would just be the sum of the
exponential of DP activation function for
any value of Waikiki.
And now we are taking the product of
this because we are assuming our uh,
our model does not model
dependencies between adjacent
positions in the sequence.
And now because the product of the
exponential is the exponential of the sum,
we can also write this as the
exponential of is some over positions,
k of the pre activation that
the output layer for each label.
Why K as predicted.
So the reactivation as computed
based on the associated input,
ex gay and a.
And then we also divide by the
product of the partition functions or
normalization constants here.
Now in the linear chain CRF in the
context of sequence classification will
essentially add a term that will also
express a preference for a particular
sequences or of AGSM and values for a
yk and why k plus one for any position
king.
So in other words,
the conditional distribution
of y given some sequence x,
it's going to be the exponential of again,
so here and here we have
exactly the same term.
So this is essentially
saying how we think,
why k the particular value of why gay
that were for which we are valuing your
probability is uh,
is,
is likely a given the input and
given the associated input x games.
So that's why we have ex gay here.
Plus another term which is going to
say how much our model likes that,
whyK is followed by why k plus one and
this so how much we like seeing why k
followed by why k plus one is going to
be parent tries by Matrix v where it's
entry yk Yq plus one uh,
tells us how much we liked this
particular sequence of yk. Why K plus one.
So just to be clear,
why k plus one is a variable
and it has a particular value.
If we have 10 classes, then
why k could be one, two,
three up to 10 and similarly why
k plus one is also a variable,
but it's the variable that represents
the label at the next step, k plus one.
And it also takes a value
from one to 10 and so v, y,
k y k plus one if a y k
four in this sequence here,
if Mikey was equal to say five and
then y k plus one was equal to three,
then this term would for this particular
value of k would look at the entry at
the fifth row and the third
column of Matrix speed. Okay.
So to sum up in a linear chain,
a conditional random fields,
we keep the per position term
that expresses how much we think,
why he should be likely given
its associated but x, k.
But we add another term which
also expresses a preference
as to whether we like
seeing why k followed by why k plus one
for a particular position over position
k.
And then notice that here also we some
from k equals one up to came and as one.
So we add our preferences for
uh, for each position. Kay.
So if we had the sequence of size,
say three,
and then we had that were valuing the
probability for y one equals se two,
and then y two equals five,
and then wide three equals uh,
let's say three,
then it means that this term
here would correspond to a right,
it just here that correspond to
v two five Plus v five three.
Okay. So if we were to compute this
expression and actually this part of the
expression for these values
for this sequence of wise,
then I'd have this term plus district.
So to sum up the probability of a
sequence y given x is going to be the
exponential of a,
some of terms which express a preference
about the value for each element in the
sequence. Why Gay? Uh,
in the sequence of labels given
the associated input plus the,
uh, some of pairwise preferences
between adjacent labels.
And so the, probably the is going to be
proportional to the exponential of the,
some of these, uh, two types of terms.
And now because we want a probability
distribution that sums to zero,
we have to divide by something
we call the partition function.
Or sometimes people use the
name normalization constant.
It's a partition function in
particular because, uh, it depends,
uh, for one thing on x, but it also
depends on the parameters of the,
uh, of the models for
different parameters. We'll
get a different value of,
of this normalization constant.
And what this zed is here is really just
the sum of the numerator but over all
possible sequence values. Uh, so all
possible values of that sequence.
Why? So there's actually a number, an
exponential number of such sequences.
And so a naive method for computing
it would be intractable, but, uh,
we'll see in a future videos out to
actually write a dynamic program for
computing the partition function for
linear chain conditional random fields.
Yeah.
Now, visually, if you
look at the, uh, uh, the,
the flow graph for computation.
So before in the regular
neural net from the input,
we'd get a computation graph up to the
pre activation layer and there would be
no interaction between this
computation for say the uh,
input that position came on as one and
the computation of the neural net at
Persia at position k that we computed
the pre activation for that particular
input.
Now what we're adding is a matrix of
undirected connections between adjacent
position such that the pre,
uh,
such that essentially the probability
will assign here will also depend on the,
uh, on what's computed here and so
on. And so this is very informal.
There's just to illustrate
the dependencies here,
and this is sort of a informal
graph of computations,
but we'll formalize this a
bit more in the next videos.
What's important to realize
that between each adjacent step,
we always use the same Matrix v as our
set of parameters that control the,
uh, interaction between, uh, and the
essentially control how we model,
uh,
observations of each sent in the sequence.
So the Matrix we hear is the same as
this matrix and so on. And similarly,
the set of weights of my neural network.
So the matrix w here and be here.
And also all the parameters that
would be between the input and the pre
activation at the output layer.
These parameters for this neural
net is the same as these, uh,
these parameters and as these
parameters. So it's sort of the, uh, uh,
the same copy of the same neural network,
uh,
with a shared weight and a, so this will
have implications when, for instance,
we compute gradients. Uh, it means that
we'll get great answers that will affect,
uh,
told that the gradients,
when do backpropagation there will be
gradient that will go on this matrix here,
which is the same as this here.
So we'll have to cumulate
gradients for each position. Okay.
But this is just to really highlight
the fact that we using the same neural
network for each position and
between adjacent position,
we using the same matrix of parameter v.
All right?
So that's the linear chain
conditional random fields.